le guardie mi stanno guardando ti hanno
fatto la foto ben 26 ma stare quasi
nuovissimo episodio k dalla prigione
proviamo una nuova mappa scorsa è stato
bellissimo non lo avete visto andate a
vederla dopo questa passato mi piace a
questa via market e raggiunge i 10 mila
vite ci proveremo
consigliata da voi vi sentite ancora
senza chiamata altrove inseguire noi
ritrovare mettetevi comodi prendete i
pop corn elefante che è così qua io
vitale stiamo in questo senso
roba da mangiare meglio farla vedere a
vitale cosa soprattutto chi è questo
guarda così c'è un passaggio segreto qua
vieni 1 sotto terra e attenzione a te
l'ho detto e verde morta forse ok
bisogna andare avanti così un palloncino
rosso ricorda qualcosa
le foglie di brezza il pagliaccio guarda
cosa c'entra cuore una prigione aiuto
meglio andare di qua dice che siamo
sotto la prigione quindi devo continuare
dobbiamo continuare andare avanti
attraverso il tunnel salta ok attento a
non cadere lo stop interno raggelato
fatto brigati doveva arrivare uno di
loro è stato facile che il grano perché
vi ricordate nella corta mappa paura che
a un certo punto era difficilissimo si
sente si comincia un padre sul caso
nuovo toccare il tubo
chiaro piano piano voli ok vediamo che
succede se sarò qui il pavimento ma vai
a salvare prima si ok ok tra mia mente
non è caduta ancora del cio stranamente
molto stranamente stavo vedendo dai sono
all'ultimo gradino quello che cos'è
questa cosa gialla qua meglio non
toccarla sto camminando soprà livello 2
già stiamo nei venti come che sarebbero
le prese d'aria o attento penso che non
bisogna far andare la via sacra sul
rosso si attenta per fortuna l'inizio da
fa dai potrà farcela
no ok forse scoperto come fare devi
andare di lato guardavi proprio
all'angolo giusti ok ci ha funzionato
no nell'ultima regata brava arriveremo
l'ultima rotondo che cos'è questo le
lame che vogliono ma sull'ultima persi
perché la gente di ha fatto volare ok ok
ho salvato aspetto qua ok arriva dai
vola voglio vederti polare o kay vitale
si saprà soltanto tre però se quindi io
vado avanti dice di non farmi no ma è
troppo difficile questo schifo mi
domando anch'io verso eccomi ma eccoti
famoso non devi farti toccare dai laser
ok dice che ci si può abbassare mai
detto ok basta possiamo scappare fatto
dove sono già molto diffusa dai puoi
farcela
bra ha assaggiato la testa adornato è
troppo divertente però bisogna stare
superattenti piano piano piano che anzi
a breve lista questa rom davvero
riusciremo a scappare dalla prigione che
cosa devo fare
ok per fortuna salvato ok dove saltare
che come tale che incasina piano piano
beh io vado breve su questa parte verde
non so come fare perché
piano piano così fatto a nozze di nuovo
la la vacua domanda come si fa qui con
con con questi risaltare saltare umano
non voglio cadere giù
la pace che è difficilissimo questo vita
resta ancora saltando le sbarre dai puoi
farcela
vai pianissimo mi raccomando se no non
ti bruci sotto questo tu pure se
qualcosa mi sono fatto vitale
sacrificando spregio all'art
beh io sono a livello 3 ma che quasi
un'altra pentola niente nessuno tu sei
ancora nella lava che succede le guardie
mi stanno guardando per la camera ti
hanno fatto una foto o no mi hanno
scoperto che sono scappata
io sto andando piano piano cielo quasi
fatta che succede tutti quanti stanno
gridando aiuto dove devo andare
dice di svegliare questo ha dissentito
svegliata bene se l'hai fatta finora
solo alla ventola ok dice ti ho bisogno
di una card per entrare qua dentro
quindi dove sarà bene che succede dentro
se no devo trovare questo accordo per
entrare nella benefattore nascosto e non
devo svegliare il poliziotto che lindsay
da allora lui dice che c'è una guardia
che sta dormendo nel tour e quindi dice
di andare a controllare come andare
nelle tubature allora usa poi le scatole
per entrare nelle prese d'aria di dove
so io quindi l'acqua bravo e attento
anno svegliarlo però è bravo io che dove
sei da solo se noto è solo dato si seguì
il corridoio troverai un anno fa un
altro 20
ce l'ho più fatta soffrire
ora dobbiamo andare là e entrare
dall'altra parte della prigione ma
ancora non siamo riusciti a scappare del
tutto da quando prumo devo dire che è
enorme quest'incarico salviamo noi loro
hanno di nuovo questi ha detto e ci sono
i poliziotti di che ci mettono la faccia
gli metto io
che cos'è bisogna salire da qui dal
tavolo con adesso a diventasse proprio
difficile eh si non posso sbagliare ha
detto se riuscita quasi sei riuscita
brizio o no quasi sono dei laser che si
muovono molto velocemente ma ci credo
sono uscite a passar qua non si
gravissimo piazzetta ora ok sono o come
fatto a superare questi credi laser ora
salvo il dice di prendere una coca cola
dalla macchina è bravo
ok lo bevuta akery proviamo allora
prendi un po di rincorsa
brava brava sempre di più ricorda che il
riproviamo
ok adesso torno a dire problemi
gravissimi sono il nostro bloccato
dietro vai sempre su quello più bassi
dall'altra parte bravo e testa
dall'altra parte e ansia perché qui poi
ci appare in un rotolo di carta igienica
gigante perché bagnato aperta sulla con
diana ma ogni tanto esco fuori dal tetto
corda che riusciva a passare a velo di
sinistra giornata ci credo salvo tutti
se questo la bellucci sono dei pezzi di
ozzy sparsa aiuto scheletriti vabbè
proviamo a saltare aiuto
tutto questo sembra molto difficile
molto pericolosa cadere qua con questo
liquido verde poi ma che lo slime
difficile ti conviene partire da questa
parte però mi sale dove devi salvare
però vediamo cos'altro se adesso ma
quant'è grande che presentano che ci
sono dei generi bakkal nicola supermario
via attenzione mai facile questo dei
cosa dobbiamo fare
dice di aspettare per di aspettare una
zattera
eccola
ok ci fa fare un giretto voi non
possiamo entrare non fare profitto più
saltare o no una vita io da rapida salta
lo faremo scappare livello siamo
soltanto quelle lucine della polizia che
ci sta cercando aiuto quindi forse
stiamo stiamo per vincere forse attenta
c'è un elicottero li attenzione dicesse
detto una volta sono morta 1234567 che
ce la possiamo fare ce la possiamo
giocare per gli
come poco più di rincorsa devi prendere
[Musica]
staffetta l'elicottero tim.it ho vinto
diminuito credo hanno sparato un
elicottero hanno sparato su per un
elicottero
non so cosa devo fare
a dire guarda sono in assoluto mi stanno
cercando piano chi ha detto sembra
facile ma è difficilissimo atteso sia
stato siamo in alto
[Musica]
quasi quasi chiaro moussa devo fare
adesso
mara cerri nella fognatura
ok attento dai stiamo per vincere penso
che stiamo per destinata ancora l'ultimo
riuscito e scappo quasi da qui ho detto
che siamo stati spediti a dal teatro
siamo stati svegli ed anche a 3 sulla
prigione più sicuro al mondo e ora devo
provare a scappare anche che se volete
vedere la seconda si possa fare anche da
alcatraz da so che mi piace se questo
video 10 mila mi piace e proveremo a
stappare anche da fare magari anche vita
mi piace di più di questa mappa attivate
quattro castellina sequi cliccare per
vedere inoltre altri video hd
televisione